Pixar's spent years making films that
are enjoyable to kids and adults alike
from Toy Story to Coco the studio has
become a favorite of moviegoers of all
ages odd word is no exception to the
rule
building a magical kid-friendly
adventure in between some pretty adult
topics and jokes onward follows Ian and
barley Lightfoot as they try to bring
their dad back from the dead for a
single day in order to get to know him
unfortunately Ian's only brings back the
bottom half of their dad leading to a
quest to find a magic gem that can bring
back his upper half before he completely
fades away at sundown as the two and a
half men go about their urgent quest
there's plenty of weekend at Bernie's
esque shenanigans and magical mix-ups to
delight the kids however adults might
find themselves wondering why the
movie's main story is about two kids
bonding with their dads but as Uproxx is
Mike Ryan so eloquently summarized this
is about two kids resurrecting their
dead dad's crotch and it's just the
weirdest thing what Pixar has managed to
stay beloved over the years other
Animation Studios have stepped up their
game Disney's non Pixar animation studio
brought the world frozen and tangled
while DreamWorks had a massive franchise
hit on its hands with How to Train Your
Dragon still even as other studios have
begun to match Pixar's artistry Pixar
movies feel unique with an incomparable
sense of style and personality that
shines through until onward that is the
20/20 movie feels like Pixar slapped a
logo over a DreamWorks film from the
character designs to the dancing
sequence in the middle
in fact onward looks like a DreamWorks
movie was a common refrain when the
trailer first dropped while it might not
go so far as to have a dance sequence as
the credits roll that might not stop
some adults from briefly forgetting
which studio made onward about halfway
through onward Ian and barley Lightfoot
get pulled over by some fantasy cops one
a cyclops played by Leena way thought
panned idli mentions her girlfriend's
daughter it's a small moment for a
character that really only shows up in a
very small scene still adults will
likely catch the implication that waits
character is gay however considering the
brief screen time for the character and
the even briefer mention of a
character's girlfriend it's unlikely
that children will catch the meaning
it's wonderful that Disney is
acknowledging the existence of lgbtq+
people in the world of their films but I
like the brief lesbian kiss and Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker these moments
tend to be fairly in
Anne Shiell hopefully the existence of
people along a gender and sexual
spectrum won't be something that only
adults notice in films going forward and
one notable set-piece ian and barley
have to figure out a way to cross a
bottomless pit in order to continue
their quest barley tells Ian about a
spell that will let him walk on air by
creating an invisible bridge that
continues to exist as long as he truly
believes in it the safety rope falls
away while Ian's halfway across but he's
already gotten the confidence to cross
the bridge by himself and doesn't notice
children might be on the edge of their
seats hoping that Ian makes it across
but the whole scene will likely feel
very familiar to the adults watching the
whole set piece feels a bit like
team-building exercises like the trust
fall or walking on hot coals or the
invisible bridge Indiana Jones had to
walk across and the Last Crusade for the
majority of the runtime of onward
viewers are likely empathizing with
Ian's quest to get to know his dad he's
the character who seems most outwardly
affected by his father's death and he's
the one who seems most eager to bring it
back as soon as possible near the end of
the film however barley reveals that he
has deep regrets over not getting the
chance to say goodbye to his dad before
he passed away during the scene the
adults in the audience might realize
that bar Lee's voice actor Chris Pratt's
had some practice playing an aging
man-child struggling to get over the
traumatic death of a parent due to a
sudden sickness after all that describes
barley just as well as it describes
Peter quill and the guardians of the
galaxy movies star-lord who legendary
outlaw even though on word is abstence
ibly set in the modern world with
touchscreen cell phones there's a
distinctly eighties sensibility to the
environment barley drives a band with a
fantasy decal on the side plays a game
similar to Dungeons & Dragons and both
Ian and barley listen to cassette decks
instead of screaming music or even CDs
even their mother Laurel gets her
exercise by watching a workout tape as
the Atlantic's David Sims wrote in his
review onward is informed by the 80s
aesthetic of tabletop games minivans
airbrushed with heavy metal album cover
arts and cookie-cutter suburban life
while plenty of kids won't even
recognize a cassette nostalgic adults
might recall their own days playing
Dungeons and Dragons and listening to
80s power ballads or at least watching
films that
those moments flat holes don't tend to
matter much in a world that literally
has magic in it still there are some
rules to the magic and onward and one
moment near the end of the film may
leave adults scratching their heads
during the battle with the dragon ian
loses his dad's magical staff but
manages to make his own by enlarging a
splinter that had gotten stuck in his
hand earlier in the pill in the epilogue
ian can be seen giving a talk to a group
of students as he stands with his
magical splinter staff however earlier
in the film it's established that
Barley's accidental shrinking because of
the spell misfiring is temporary what
kids are enjoying the epilogue adults
might be wondering whether objects made
larger are also temporary or whether
that only applies to shrunk objects if
Ian can make things permanently larger
does this lead to a Cloudy with a Chance
of Meatballs type situation or to see
Ian just grow his splinter whenever he
wants to use his staff can anyone
explain this please to explain it ah
yeah well whenever you notice something
like that a wizard it nicely alright yes
but in Episode a G for wizard check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]